you and your son are on a totally normal
flight saved for the lack of any
passengers and you're ripped from the
sky and into the forest below to
battered to intervene you watch as an
oil slick nudist cannibal takes your son
from the wreckage like an arm full of so
much filet mignon so begins the forest
an open-world sandbox survival sim that
thank Christ is not about zombies with
my son most likely rendered into beef
stew somewhere within walking distance I
grabbed a convenient axe for my
stewardesses chestplate start hacking
apart suitcases like a meth addled TSA
agent and hike into the maw the
woodlands for a new life of vengeance
the perfect home presents itself quickly
I chop down a dozen trees build a little
shelter roast up a lizard listen to the
birds singing and I'm thinking that
maybe things aren't so bad after all oh
you gotta be [ __ ] kidding me
alright so this place is actually a
horrifying cannibal hell realm of some
sort but you know they didn't eat me or
murder me they just sort of put me in a
cave with oh oh go God there are some
memories that only prescription drug
abuse can erase the forest is a game
that hinges on the counterpoint between
two types of experience the first of
these fits squarely into the horror
genre there's an ambient terror that
hangs over every play through distant
noises suggest encroaching death and
prevent any tranquility lasting more
than a naive second blood soaked
campsites and effigies constructed out
of human remains or foreboding to say
the least and create a ubiquitous sense
of danger more overt scares come from
the entire island of cannibals as they
attempt to sample your flesh watching
them wander the hillsides and groups or
congregated small encampments makes
these natives feel like living breathing
predators with depth and intelligence
instead of just faceless villains
then there's the unexpectedly beautiful
side of the forest oh no God not that
the beautiful side of the forest a
serene cliff view calls you to adventure
sweet little birds gather in your
shelter the stars hang like lanterns
above reflected light plays off a cave
wall the novelty of exploration in this
experience takes flight when rolling
hills give way to explorable caves or a
sea cliff with an abandoned yacht below
it makes me want to uncover this world
instead of feeling obligated to due to
its alpha state there aren't quite
enough of these set pieces in the forest
yet but the
is there overall the forest is an
impressive game in spite of its many
glitches in its unfinished state the
experience needs to be fleshed out with
more to discover in the edition of end
goals to motivate players actions but
there is enough in this early access
title to get me excited for the finished
product